more unpopular nutrition truths that
Wellness influencers don't want you to
know living off of salt and vinegar
chips during pregnancy is far less
dangerous for baby's Health than not
being able to eat much at
all if sugar and food dyes encourage
your sick kid to take their meds they're
more of a superfood than blueberries and
peas a high protein diet does not damage
your kidneys it is physically very very
hard to overdose on chicken weight loss
isn't primarily about blood sugar or
insulin spikes it will always come down
to a calorie
deficit
most intermittent fasters eating from
12:00 till 6:00 aren't even reaping the
benefits they'd get if they had
breakfast and skipped dinner insulin
isn't inherently bad for your health
it's actually imperative for muscle
growth and
repair cutting out too many foods out of
fear that it may cause bloating may
actually be the true cause of your
bloating which of these nutrition truths
are going to make the most Wellness
influencers mad